like a lot of people around the world
earlier this summer my friends and I
were obsessed with the Women's World Cup
held in France here we are watching this
incredible athletes the the goals were
amazing the games were clean and
engaging and at the same time outside
the field these women are talking about
equal pay and in the case of some
countries any pay at all for their sport
so because we were mildly obsessed we
wanted to watch the games live and we
decided that one of the spanish-speaking
networks in the US was the best place
for us to start and he wasn't until a
few games into a tournament that a
friend of mine talks to me and says why
does it feel like everything I'm seeing
is commercials for makeup and household
cleaning products and diets he did feel
a little bit too obvious and I don't
know if we were sensitive about it or
the fact that we were watching what with
men and boys in our lives but he did
feel a little bit too obvious that we're
being targeted for being women and to be
honest there's nothing necessarily wrong
with that someone sat down and look at
the tournament and said well this thing
is likely to be seen by more women this
women are Hispanic because they're
watching in Spanish and this is women
content therefore this is a great place
for me to place all these commercials
that are female centric and maybe not
other things if I think about it as a
marketer I know that I absolutely should
not be annoyed about it because this is
what marketers are tasked we doing
marketers are tasked with building
brands with very limited budget so
there's a little bit of an incentive to
categorize people in buckets so they can
reach their target faster so if you
think about this is kind of like a
shortcut they're using gender as a
shortcut to get to their target consumer
the issue is that as logical as that
argument seems gender as a shortcut it's
actually not great in this day and age
if you still blindly use a gender view
for your marketing activities actually
it's just plain bad business I'm not
talking even about the backlash and
stereotypes another
Theisen which is a very real thing that
has to be addressed I'm saying it's bad
business because you're leaving money on
the table for your brands and your
products because gender is such an easy
thing to find in the market and to
target and to talk about it actually
distracts you from the fun things that
could be driving girls from your brands
and at the same time it continues to
create separation around genders and
perpetuating stereotypes so at the same
time this activity is bad for your
business and bad for society so double
whammy and gender is one of those things
like other demographics that have
historically been good marketing
shortcuts at some point however we
forgot that at the core we were
targeting needs around cooking and
cleaning and personal care and driving
and sports and we just made it all the
bucket and we said men and women are
different we got used to it and we never
challenge it again and it's fascinating
to me and my fascinating I mean a little
bit insane that we still talk about this
as a segment when it's most likely
carryover bias in fact I don't come to
this conclusion lightly we have enough
data to suggest that gender is not the
best place to start for you to design
and target your brands and I would even
go one step further unless you're
working in a very gender specific
product category probably anything else
you're hypothesizing about your consumer
right now it's gonna be more useful than
gender we did not set up to draw this
conclusion specifically we found it as
consultants or job is to go with our
clients and understand their business
and try to help them find spaces for
their brands to grow and it is or belief
that if you want to find disruptive
growth in the market you have to go to
the consumer and take a very agnostic
view of the consumer you have to go and
look at them from scratch remove
yourself from biases and segments that
you thought very important just take a
look to see where the growth is and we
build ourselves to an algorithm
precisely for that so imagine that we
have a person and we know a person is
making a choice about a product or
service and from this person I can know
their gender of course other
demographics where they live their
income other things I know the context
with
person is making a decision where they
are who they are with the energy
anything and I can also put other things
in the mix I can know their attitudes
how they feel about the category their
behaviors so if you imagine this kind of
blob of big data about a person I'm
gonna oversimplify the science here but
we basically built an algorithm for
statistical tournaments so a statistical
tournament is like asking this big thing
of data show data from everything you
know about consumers at this point what
is the most useful thing I need to know
that tells me more about what consumers
need so the tournament is gonna have
winners and losers the winners are those
variables those dimensions that actually
teach you a lot about your consumer that
if you know that you know what they need
and there's losing variables that are
just not that practical and this matters
because in a world of limited resources
you don't want to waste it on people
that actually have the same needs so why
treat them differently so at this point
I know suspense is not killing you
because I told you what the output is
but what we found over time is after 200
projects around the world this is
currying 20 countries or more in essence
we've around about a hundred thousand of
this tournaments and no surprise gender
was very rarely the most predictive
thing to understand consumer needs from
a hundred thousand tournaments gender
only came out of the winning variable in
about five percent of them this is true
around the world by the way we did this
in places where traditional gender roles
leather a little more pronounced and the
conclusions was exactly the same it was
a little bit more important gender than
5% but not material
so let's let that sink in for a second
no matter how you're looking at a
consumer most likely anything else is
going to be more interesting to you than
gender there's probably something very
important you need to know about them
and you're getting distracted because
you're doing everything based on gender
and that's why I say you're leaving
money on the table
gender is easy it's easy to design
advertising based on gender it's easy to
target people online and on TV based on
gender but at the end that's not where
the exciting growth will come from if
you're a food company for example
is actually much more interesting to you
to know where people are eating where
who they are eating with are they very
nutritionally oriented all of those
things are actually significantly more
powerful and useful than knowing if a
person is a man or a woman and that
matters of course because then if you're
putting your limited budget into action
then you're better off creating
solutions for different occasions and
trying to target women versus young men
another example is alcoholic beverages
35% to 40% of consumption in alcoholic
beverages around the world actually
happens with women but you know women
don't drink beer those are the things
that we typically hear but actually when
a man and a woman are for the most part
in the same location the emotional and
functional and needs they have at that
moment are very similar there's only one
exception by the way and the exceptions
exist where if you have a man on a woman
on a date the man is trying to impress
the woman and the woman is trying to
connect with a man so there's gonna be a
little bit of tension but that's
important to know we'll take a few dates
financial institutions that's something
where we've heard a lot about the
difference between men and women but
actually talking about men and women is
different actually it's distracting you
from the thing that is underneath we
made it so simple as women don't like to
invest
women hate managing their money men are
great and aggressive and risk takers but
at the end is not about men and women it
is actually a different narrative it is
about there are people that are excited
and energized and educated to manage
their finances versus people that are
not so if you change the conversation
from men and women to actually what's
underneath then probably you'll stop
being so condescending to women and you
may start serving some men that I
actually shy about managing their
finances I'll leave one more example if
I go back to the women that we're
playing sport at the beginning one of
the fascinating things we found over
different countries exploring sports
where that if a person is a competitive
person and they are in the moment of
action the needs are not different
between a man and a woman an athlete is
an athlete it doesn't matter for men and
women is a matter for old and young you
are an athlete and in the moment of
action and extreme competition you
need this year to work for you so the
soccer-playing women have a lot in
common with their counterparts out of
the field it doesn't matter out of the
field they may be into fashion to other
things but on the field the needs are
not different so these are just a few
examples on categories where we found
that gender was not the best place to go
and actually the argument is that at
this point it's not even a feminist push
it's just we got used to it we got used
to using gender and it's important for
us to start finding ways to measure
other things about consumer said that we
don't revert back to gender I am not
naive and I know there's still gonna be
appetite and certain ease around using
gender but at least these warrants a
conversation in your business you have
to inquire is this really the best lens
for me to grow so if you are like me a
person that is in business that I am
constantly worried about what is my role
in the broader societal discussions if
you're listening to your business and
you hear things like oh my target are
women my target are men let's go to
worry young girls young boys when it's a
gender conversation unless you're
working again in a very specific gender
specific product category take this as a
warning sign because if you keep having
these conversations you will keep
perpetuating stereotypes of people and
making people think that men and women
are different but because this is
business and we're running a business
and we want to grow it at least kind of
challenge your own instinct to use
gender because statistics say that
you're probably not choosing the best
variable to target your product or
service growth is not easy at all what
makes you think that growth is going to
come from going into market with such an
outdated lens that gender so let's stop
doing what's easy and go for what's
right at this point is not just for your
business it's for society thank you
[Applause]